yeah welcome Leon to the studio and
Happy Thanksgiving for you today is it
the first time that you're celebrating
this holiday in the US yes yes what are
the plans well I have friends uh over
from New York so they're going to
introduce me to the Thanksgiving oh yeah
okay so it's going to be a great
experience today so but before that we
had to play you had to play the game and
I feel also like I'm playing with you
guys you know that's why I say we had to
play so what happened in this one Yan
mentioned that he mixed up something in
the opening so how how did it look for
you from your side yeah I thought that
uh Bishop A6 is a bit of a dubious idea
and uh I actually liked my
position um of course I have many ways
to proceed in this position I mean
Knight B5 is quite tempting generally I
mean just strategical but I thought this
queen2 E4 is very direct and could be
very strong and I kind of like my
position I mean of course white has many
options in this position you know uh I
was thinking of Queen D3 also possible
but I thought you know this end game
should be very pleasant and uh like you
have this better paone structure yeah so
far I thought what I was doing made
sense but then I think G4 is a terrible
move I actually uh really missed this uh
D4 um idea M because it was not possible
prior to that and then uh I kind of um
got carried away because my position was
so nice yeah I just should just play
Slowly you know just Rook C1 King F2
King to F3 and I think it's a very
pleasant position for white you know
just
uh not necessarily winning but um like
Pleasant it's an edge yeah it's an edge
you can you can play
Forever can you explain a
why why you think that it's so good for
what I mean because some I mean we can
see the variation of the computer say
for example Rook c16 King F2 because I
mean strategically there is much more uh
risk for black because uh so this Pawn
is easily blocked and uh I I do have a
plan to push with
F5 while uh for him you know it's it's
difficult to find like a concrete plan
So eventually you know I will push G4
and I will get what I want because once
the pawn goes to D3 Bishop B3 so Black's
Knight is not being activated and
therefore White's
Advantage can be significant here mhm I
understand so let's say this G4 was the
critical moment of the game and after
that yes because when he played kn6 I
thought F5 I actually thought the whole
sole point of knight6 is to play Knight
G7 here MH uh Bishop G5 Rook D7 I
thought that that this is this is what I
was looking at you know and then D4 I
thought this is very interesting because
I can play a rook e one or Rook D1 and
try to
play6 maybe I was still overestimating
my chances if it's
nothing um but I no it looks really
optically so good for white Ian try to
play it with black I don't know why
computer is so optimistic for black but
it doesn't look so well yeah for yeah
somehow maybe I'm not in time
yeah but uh yeah after after D4 um yeah
I didn't believe in Bishop H7 Al I saw
that possibility I thought definitely
not going to work so I decided you know
to call it a day just to just to play
solid because this is clearly a drawish
position so and the game finished at the
end in the draw U how can you estimate
assess your participation so far three
rounds already finished the game with
Saab yesterday
yeah it it was not one of my proudest
moments I I really overestimated my
position yesterday I I thought that with
uh The Rook against the bishop I can
never be worse but uh because of lots of
um tactical uh reasons my my position is
very difficult to play so but then I
really got lucky yeah I like the moment
when you start pushing G5 you know still
hoping to create some quarter was like I
think good attempt and five somehow
didn't find also the the correct moves
yeah there I you know I couldn't be
really second guessing there I I just
had to play something because it can be
very dangerous this type of positions
for sure and young Krist Duda withdrew
from the tournament today um what do you
think about the situation right now well
he's a brilliant player I mean what all
we can wish for is for him to get
healthy you know and uh I mean he's a
really really nice person and uh I look
forward to be seeing him in our
tournaments I hope uh he will recover
quickly yeah ever happened to you that
you were playing ill during the
tournaments or withdrew from the
tournament have have this ever happened
to you before uh once I was on the verge
of withdrawing I got a food poisoning a
terrible food poisoning in Mexico City
in 20
7 the world championship mhm and
um I decided to play but uh throughout
the tournament I would be just crying I
I I I would be just uh you know getting
in the resting area and just oh my God
just to cry yeah cuz I was feeling so
sick I I Got U I think I got some sort
of a disent oh my gosh this was really
you still kep
playing yes yes but CH players they
never give up you know they always keep
playing I remember myself fever whatever
I would still come and play well you
know this was the my first candidate and
I qualified there by winning the World
Cup and after winning World Cup I had to
play two matches to qualify yes and I
beat Magnus Carlson and I beat Alexa
shirov so how can you withdrew from this
yeah no it's not possible right I
remember also you haven't played in so
one time right that you had to cancel
but it happened before yeah that time I
was really really ill I think it was I
wasn't sure but I think it was a CO I I
also think I got Co during the Olympia
in
India history have a history here okay
one really all the best of luck for you
stay healthy everything should be fine
and Happy Thanksgiving once again and we
are going back to the studio to you guys
thank you Anastasia and thank you Leon
for sharing his thoughts with us he
looked a little bit